[Music]
what up guys
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever
we want and today we're going to talk
about
what do we learn about ourselves i like
how it's like whatever we want
and then you have
you know what that's like well it's like
couldn't you ask your girl like what you
want to eat yeah
anything like what about talk about
except for that
anything about that oh my god i heard
there's a trick to that
is there what is it so it's like uh when
she's like oh what should we eat and
then
you'd be like can you guess what i'm
thinking i know you i know you're gonna
like it and she's like
is it this and then you're like yep and
she's like oh
[ __ ] i might try that yeah see if it
works okay i heard that's the trick i'm
gonna get into a game yeah make her
kind of re-engineer the way she would
actually come up with an idea for once
yeah because they they do know
sometimes like you know sometimes you
don't know i've been
with geo for what like [ __ ] 12 years
now
then she's never knows she just knows
everything she doesn't want
yeah but she doesn't know what she is
yeah it's funny when we come over and
she's like
anything and then you're like this and
she's like no
and she's like just order it's fine and
then she was like
i just eat later and then she and you're
like you didn't give me food i'm like
oh this is crazy yeah because for me
when i say anything you saw the whole
thing it's literally anything
you know yeah like she'll even try to
say something like as if it's gonna
throw me off like
pizza i'm like yeah i said literally
anything
but for chicks because it's just not geo
but i hear it a lot and i think that's
why it's a meme
it is a [ __ ] meme yeah that's crazy
it's like no matter what you say
it's it's it's like they just ask you to
shut you down
i'm i'm the same where i'm like it could
literally be anything if you want to go
to 7-eleven just go through the [ __ ]
aisles and pick [ __ ]
i can either get a bean and cheese
burrito yeah we can do whatever or just
chips and cookies you know uh yeah
but i think they like it when you're
decisive decisive
yeah not really because i'm really
decisive because i really like food
right
yeah because i'll be like i know what i
want i want [ __ ] linguine and clams
and then they're like oh no
my when restaurants are open my tastes
are a little bit more
expensive because i like restaurants i
enjoy that spot damn you bougie fool
not even i just enjoy they're not even
expensive but it's just people like
let's go to this nice restaurant
let's do this and it's like you can
order a few different things from there
there's like a lot of things to order
yeah but it's like kind of an adventure
yeah you know what continental breakfast
france the one that i thought was like
all these restaurants are [ __ ] done
and i start to see them pivot that's
crazy are the korean bbq spots
you know they have full-on stations
right and i'm like oh you guys are
[ __ ] done
because you can't do this to go yeah and
then i see these [ __ ] start
moving the stations outside
and i'm like that is crazy these guys
are dead last
day of lockdown yeah we went to get some
korean barbecue oh
ty yeah i miss it though cause like all
the korean bbq spots
i go to like quarters quarters like
arguably one like the the highest
quality ones you could get
yeah um [ __ ]
okay like i don't want to say anything
bad so but it's like
it's not what it's supposed to be so
it's like if you're not going to
quarters for that quality
go to somewhere else because you're not
able to grill it they just cook it and
bring it out ah that's not the same
it's not the same no there's spots
though where it's just
basically a restaurant outside in a tent
but that's what i'm saying so go to that
over quarters oh yeah i mean because if
you're going for that experience
that's even if it's a cheap 10 spot it's
gonna be way
better than you spending a hundred
dollars a quarters man i feel so bad for
a lot of the restaurants that aren't
gonna survive
during so many closed down it sucks man
it sucks how it went down like this
it's crazy how some of these restaurants
were like the most popular spot so like
i go to portland a lot i go to portland
as much as i go to like hawaii
um like every year we'll go to hawaii
every year i'll go to portland are there
a lot of
uh strict desires too or or more i'm not
too sure i think it's i think it's
pretty
strict on like the liberal areas um but
pak pak is a it was a thai restaurant
right
you can't get here for like two or three
hours it's super popular
they closed down oh [ __ ] damn all these
other restaurants are like closing down
all over the place all over the country
even um
big like celebrities have restaurants
like uh uh with uh david chang
yeah oh yeah he had to he had to uh
in development of a few or one i think
like washington dc or something yeah
exactly the soup plantation is never
coming back man
that place doesn't need to come back no
i love souffle
the corn the cornbread and the butter
the the
everything dude like i love vegetables
uh plus like going
but their vegetables are [ __ ] no i like
so like growing up
uh because my dad had a store in the
mall so i basically grew up in a mall
right like we'll go there all with like
food court food food
corn food would have thing called fresh
choice and then that like uh is
literally the exact i think they're
the same company it could be like
hardy's and carl's jr yeah so
it's like fresh choice red tomatoes and
then
uh or whatever plantation it's literally
the same exact food same layout same
trays
everything um but we'll go get the soups
get the salad
fill it up and then you get like the
pizza that they make oh yeah
and the in the soups that would mix the
clam to half clam chowder half a
chicken noodle soup oh [ __ ] and then you
go and get the [ __ ] saucer ice cream
and put [ __ ] on the oreos and mix it
up oh dude that place is the reason one
of the reasons i'm fat that in hometown
but
dude did you used to um you know how
they had baked potato
so you smash that full up you go to the
chili you
pour that on top sour cream cheese all
that
oh man you smash it up that [ __ ] was
really good
all but there's ways of being fat in
healthy spots
you just have to you have to have the
right mindset you have to be poor too
i think growing up like that gave me
like mainly being fat
but that gave me like the incentive of
being like these dope spots like get
like the protein out of it get the
to get the good stuff does your family
still own the uh furniture store
no this was like i think maybe
seven years ago we stopped oh [ __ ]
imagine if they had that now
because i heard a lot of furniture
stores were curtained too yeah i think
like
so most people don't want to shop retail
so i think this year it was like
the craziest record for online shopping
and i think especially furniture stores
they
most people just buy it online now man
that's pretty good
plus our [ __ ] wasn't like ikea stuff
it's like stuff that you'll have for
years and pass on and it's like oh we we
had we literally had i think like two or
three million dollars worth of inventory
that we just had to give up
and then uh so it would be like because
our rugs would be like twenty thousand
dollars
damn it'll be like once every two months
one baller would just come
and just was walking around the mall and
saw it and was like [ __ ] pull out
hella cash and like
they buy one and it got to the point
where we're just selling them for like
was your dad stressing the [ __ ] out the
whole month
and finally sells a rug he's like oh
thank god i don't know my dad can go
not pay like somehow they're like you
didn't play around in like years and
he's still like
working well i don't know
when it's frugal but like crazy at the
same time yeah
so yeah the restaurants that are like
the ones that have been like
the hot spot in that city the one those
ones going down
that those ones break my heart yeah yeah
it just sucks because
there's just people that actually
did well during this time like all of a
sudden their business wasn't doing good
and then like it skyrocketed because of
kovid like zoom
i feel like because people are like
doing skype right yeah probably
the guy that invented zoom was like how
am i ever gonna beat skype
well [ __ ] facetime yeah yeah and for
some reason
boom zoom blows the [ __ ] up i heard
about
boba shops they were uh like some that
weren't doing so hot before quarantine
but afterwards it started to like really
pick up because no one
they were like what do you want to do i
don't know just go grab some boba oh
the i think the hard thing is so imagine
like all those spots that
relied on a bunch of like say like these
people that worked
like serving a lot of restaurants are
also just open takeout only
so they don't need the servers they have
to like follow them or whatever
uh so it's hard dude i go so gio's
favorite
a vegetarian place is called happy fam
on atlantic oh that place is good this
place is really good
but i even see them starting to
diversify
like you go in there and uh because we
order takeout they're from sometimes
there'll be a table and then you could
buy like some sandals
or you could buy like some [ __ ] some
matches
because i think for them they're just
not getting the amount of traffic so
they're like
we gotta sell some [ __ ] to keep this
place alive i think
once you kind of like figure out like
say your business and like
adapting to the times it is almost in a
sense like
like definitely i would have lost sleep
to not being able to sell things yeah if
you own like a brick and mortar business
like that yeah and then once like you
kind of figure it out that like
it in a sense almost be more common that
you can start your business back up
yeah yeah a bunch of my friends who are
food blog bloggers
they've been working in partnership with
like restaurants that need help
they'll uh just come in and just
like all of a sudden promote it on tick
tock or whatever and it's like a line
out the door
and like rescue these shops so they're
just going all over california doing
this stuff
would you say that's calming for you
good segue i'm just trying to explain
today's video is brought to you by calm
if you're
going through some problems you're up
late at night
you need some sleep and you're just kind
of like man i don't know
what my business is gonna what's gonna
happen to my business
we have this awesome app called com
where you can actually get some sleep
because 2020 has
been a lot and we could all benefit from
the
less stress and more sleep in our lives
it's so important to take care of
ourselves
and invest in our well-being during the
times of anxiety
and that's why we're excited to partner
with calm the app designed to help you
ease stress
and get the best sleep of your life and
when you relieve anxiety and
improve your sleep you feel better in
every part of your life
calm has a whole library of programs
designed for healthy sleep
like soundscapes guided meditations and
over a hundred sleep stories narrated by
soothing voices like
stephen fry kelly roland and laura dern
over 85 million people around the world
use
calm to take care of their minds and get
better sleep and if you go to kong.com
off the record you'll get a limited time
offer of 40
off a calm premium subscription which
includes
hundreds of hours of programming get the
call map
and experience a transformation in the
way you sleep for listeners of the show
com is offering a special limited time
promotion of 40 off
a calm premium subscription at calm.com
off the record that's 40 off unlimited
access to comms entire library
and new content is added every week go
to com.com that's calm.com
off the record oh yeah i think one thing
that like
quarantine and like this year has taught
me is to really just like
like in a selfish way like focus on
myself the things that i want to do but
all like in a sense that helps out like
everyone around you
but like this year was the year that was
like [ __ ] just life is short
do the things that you want to i want to
get tattoos i want to get my teeth fixed
i want to travel
i want to do like that's true you did a
lot of like transformation stuff yeah
and it's
cool because it's more of who i've
wanted to be
nice tattoos and tea i got this i got
this
i got this wow i got this wow would you
say
you went all out at once dude yeah i'm
getting a bunch of if
like let's say 2020 didn't happen it was
like a normal 20 20.
you don't think you would got all those
things uh it would have prolonged it
um but at the beginning of quarantine so
i was talking to
uh our friend from the gym the one that
got us on drunk cooking
yeah sorry drunk history yeah um so then
when i was talking oh yeah i was
supposed to be on that too i was so
excited so i was like i wanted to get an
acting right so i was like [ __ ] it and
then that just
like life happens like that or he's been
saying like oh like let's do stuff and
he's always like send me your scripts
let's do this
um i was gonna play a japanese a world
famous japanese weightlifter
really yeah because he works with tommy
connor no
so he's actually american-based
japanese-american oh um but there was a
drunk cooking on comedy central history
drunk history
on uh uh comedy central and so they
needed a guy to play like a japanese
weightlifter
and i was going to play him i was so
excited yeah so then uh
because of kovid yeah so everything got
shut down so then because of that i was
like oh i was just we're just talking i
was like i want to get tattoos and like
all this stuff but of acting and they're
like dude you can cover it up
like obviously like smaller scale
they'll probably pick someone that's not
fully tatted or
whatever just so it saves some money but
like at the bigger scale like
they're not gonna turn down like a
anyone like they can easily do makeup on
things and most of the time is
they put makeup on the rock 50 cent all
the time yeah so it's like
i can wear a shirt and cover it up so
it's like simple things that you you can
do
or just like like it's so easy like when
i go back home i just put some like
so to my more like muslim family your
parents don't know no my family does my
mom was so excited that i got her name
teddy
oh that's her name yeah because she was
like no don't i was like i'm gonna get
your name tagged she's like
it's yours and she started drawing her
name is that her handwriting she's like
oh my son
loves me she like drew it because
there's different ways of writing it but
this is the way that afghans would
and like in arabic it's like spelled
like this do you go left to right or
right to left
uh right to left arabic looks so tight
dude yeah it's super sick
so i definitely want a lot more like
arabic on me and then uh um
i'll say i want my grandma's name and
she's like please get that soon just so
you have like some like protection with
you like her name with you always
so you have your family or your mom's
name on your left okay this is my family
name
yeah so it's like it's close to your
heart that's why i got yeah same concept
down here
close to my heart and then uh but it's
like everything that i wanted to do i'm
like
just do it you know and then things that
kind of like it reshaped my thinking of
what would actually make me happy i
think kind of like you too or like all
of us where it's less like
traveling more hanging out with family
uh being with friends or
whatever it may be that i've kind of got
time to really figure out and think
because i was more in the sense of like
all our work is like say social media
but like you kind of get caught up in
that world of like especially me at a
young age with like the people i hang
out with
that are like literally the people we
talk about and all these things
and then i'm like that's what thing but
i see them not being happy and i'm like
what's actually going to make me happy
so i got to see from both sides yeah
more followers isn't going to make you
happy or more money
i think yeah i think like for 2020 it's
been like a giant
almost like a reset for like the whole
world and i think
people uh they thought they're bound by
these unnecessary like strings
yeah and i think for once everyone's
like oh [ __ ] i don't need to be bound by
these things
yeah like people that used to have to go
into work every day
they're like wait i can actually work
from home and live anywhere
and i think that's a pretty big game
changer our society is going to change
now because we can still operate without
living close to the big city um you know
minimalism is becoming more
accepted instead of like hey what are
you doing
yeah and a van life exploded yeah a
whole
whole new entire like industries that
were just kind of like kind of
simmering or like boom like everyone's
oh that's tight yeah things that i
thought was good
correcting itself huh it's weird like
like the stuff that you're into
yeah it's like it's correcting itself
where it's like almost taking a step
back
but like it feels like we're going this
way and we went this way but we went
back to actually go this way like
the technology that we're using isn't
like as important and we're going like
like less it's weird how it's going both
ways in a sense
yeah i mean like when i got into this
stuff like eight
and seven years ago or something and
then
i've always kind of watched it but i was
like oh yeah when i retire or like maybe
later
and i was i don't know why i always had
that mentality yeah of like
i don't have enough money i don't have
enough this i have a [ __ ] ton of money
in it
but like in my in my head i don't have
enough you know
i mean that's when i was thinking about
it like it's like there's a lot of
people who do this with very little or
nothing
i mean the whole idea of it is like to
not spend anything
but then in my head i'm i'm constantly
thinking like oh i don't have enough
like i'm too poor
but it's a poor mentality that kept me
scared
instead of like no you do have enough
why don't you just do it
yeah i think that was a lot of it was
unnecessary um fears and limitations
because i always thought that
i whatever i set my mind to i do it
right
but then this was a big awakening for me
where i'm like
oh i actually was afraid to just pull
the trigger on a lot of things
or i felt like i didn't deserve it like
i shouldn't be camping with my friends
because i have all these other things i
gotta run but i'm like
really though did i really have to i
just i just couldn't
focus and give myself that time to
breathe
because even if we are going out and
doing something the back of my mind i'm
thinking should i be filming this
or like maybe feel guilty huh yeah like
should we be
working we have so much stuff we got to
finish and like
yeah it was just unnecessary uh pressure
that i created in my own mind
yeah i like cause i think we're
definitely like it hit everyone pretty
hard at first and then like some people
bounce off good some people realize that
they
like reallocate money in different areas
and not spending it i've had friends
that kind of got hit harder because they
literally just lost all the work
yeah but they've changed it so one of
our friends was a teacher
from seattle and then when he he moved
out here during covet to be closer to
his family
couldn't everyone want to be a teacher
online so then he couldn't find a job so
he turned to uh
reselling go to vintage jobs do that and
he's making way more than he
ever was i had other friends that just
looked around their house and they're
like i don't use the [ __ ] anymore let me
sell this online
and start becoming frugal but now i have
the necessary knowledge of how to do
that
yeah um so because like there's a lot of
people that just been hit
super hard just like i might lose my
house i might do this that they turn to
things that like
america especially we have so much junk
that we don't need yes lying around the
house that we could get rid of like
most of it and like be happy it all
depends on like
uh the job like some jobs got hit hard
yeah and then we have a friend too where
the minute
kovit came around and then there was
like kovid pay in the hospital he's like
[ __ ] yeah i make 75 an hour i'm like you
make 75 an hour that's [ __ ] crazy
he goes this is awesome yeah because
they were getting like hazard pay
plus coveted pay and all that stuff and
it's yeah it's crazy how
like as a nurse i'm like god damn your
ball he goes yep i'm saving that's like
double right
i think he was getting triple because he
also works at uh
like one of the best hospitals so i
think it's just everything has
like shoe layers on top of it yeah it's
kind of like how
death is pretty close to us like we know
people
that's like um not in our circle but
like
a friend of a friend or someone who's
passed and then that
is a wake-up call to like hey life is
short
and some people you can tell like do
they
get extra paranoid now and extra careful
or do they go
well [ __ ] this i'm gonna like live my
life
because life is short and then you kind
of see how like
everyone's dealing with it differently
there's you know
some people that are like all right i'm
gonna go into my chamber and just
wait until all this dies and i'm gonna
come out alive
when the apocalypse is over yeah and
then some people are like well [ __ ] it
i'm gonna go
into the fire and see if i can survive i
have this friend that's just weird
her dad's a uh doomsday prepper or like
that type yeah
and i was like he must be so [ __ ]
like rubbing in your face now
i've been telling you for 30 years yeah
he's like in his [ __ ]
cage that he built underground and he's
like i told you [ __ ] you have all these
cans of chili for fun
yeah i like chili
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]